لا يوجد اي سيناريو لوجودنا هنا الا
للاستماع للائحه الاتهامات التي تم كشف
النقاب عنها
هل تعتقدون ان ما يتم الحديث عنه بشان
احداثه يناير ان هذا امر واقعي ماذا بشان
حاله الوحده بين صفوف
المواطنين
لقد كنا نعمل سويا
ومن خلال جمله من المحاميين وانه لشرف لي
ان اعمل مع هذا الرجل فاننا فريق واحد ما
هي الخطوه المقبله
متى سوف تقدمون سوف تتقدمون بطلبات الى
المحكمه لرد
هذه الدعوه
انتم تفهمون القصه ان
المدعي العام
هو الذي بدا
بتقديمي لائحه الاتهامات هذه
بناء على ما خلص اليه
المحلفون
تغيير
مقر المحاكمه
لم لم نتطرق الى اي نقاشات في هذا السؤال
في هذا الموضوع
لماذا يسعل لنقل مكان المحاكمه اننا ثلاثه
محاميين هنا نحارب من اجل هذه القضيه نحن
لسنا مستشارين بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لقد وصل الرئيس ترامب الى سده الحكم
بصرف النظر عما كان يكتبهم الرسائل على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لا يمكننا ان
نعلق على ما يكتبه من تعليقات على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
لا استطيع ان اخبركم ما الذي ناقشناه
بصوره اساسيه
لكن الحديث عن القاضي والحديث عن اسرتي
لكن
بالنسبه لاي مودع عام اخر لو كان هناك اي
مدعي عام مدعي عليه اخر فلن يكون موجودا
في هذه القاعه
قيل بان الذكر بان ترامب بانه غاضب من
المدعي العام وقد لا تتفقون مع ما اشار
اليه
انه مستعد للقتال
للقتال في المعركه
هل تعتقدون ان هذه توم سوف تبقى كلا بكل
تاكيد